straight tall and majestic the Christmas
tree outside Windsor Castle the main
residence of Queen Elizabeth the second
stands 12 metres high and 4 metres wide
the Nordmann fir comes from cobalt
germany the home city of the Queen's
great-great-grandfather in her Christmas
speech last year the Queen mentioned
that the Christmas tree used back when
Albert married Queen Victoria came from
Kobuk Isle staff noted that and so we
decided to write a letter to the Queen
and offer her a tree for Christmas the
city of Cobourg sent its letter to Queen
Elizabeth offering her a Christmas tree
from cobourg forest with traditional
decoration the Queen's staff quickly
replied saying she would be delighted
with the gift back in Windsor local mare
sayonara Luxton drops by to take a look
at the results it's such an honor to
have something like this come from
Germany to Great Britain especially in
our town or Windsor and we are really
privileged to have that tree down here
where we can especially with all the
decoration that y'all have given Esther
and it looks amazing it's beautiful
beautiful it all started when the German
Prince Albert of saxe-coburg and Gotha
married Queen Victoria it said he
introduced the tradition of the
Christmas tree to Britain in 1848 when
he installed one at Windsor Castle
Albert and Victoria are Queen
Elizabeth's great-great grandparents
prints concert Albert was born here in
Rosso Castle near Cobourg in 1819 some
of his descendants still live in the
area including who bear to us hereditary
Prince of saxe-coburg who donated this
year's Christmas tree to the Queen it
had to be between 10 and 12 meters high
and no more than 4 meters wide because
there's a changing of the guard at
Windsor Castle directly behind the Queen
Victoria statue the guards have to move
past the tree without touching it it was
a challenge to find a tree with the
right dimensions but we're happy we
found a beautiful one with a straight
trunk the 30 year old Nordmann fir was
felled in Cobourg forest and given an
official send-off before it began its
1000 kilometer trip across Germany and
the English Channel to Britain
a few days later the tree had completed
the long trip and now stands outside
Windsor Castle the residence of the
British monarchs is the largest and
oldest continuously inhabited castle in
the world and is now Queen Elizabeth's
primary home the timing of this latest
gift from Cobourg could be strategic
we'll be celebrating a prince albert's
200th birthday in a couple of years time
with events that are already being
planned and we have a great wish a goal
and call it a dream that we will be able
to welcome someone from the British
royal family would be a major feather in
our cap the tree has been decorated with
about 2,000 Christmas baubles made in
the town of Lao sure it's not far from
cobourg and is famous for its glass
ornaments the decorations were
commissioned especially for the Queen's
tree and took six months to produce
it's very special because the baubles
are handmade we produced them from glass
tubes that were more than 30 years old
the tubes used to be manufactured near
Lucia it took two days to securely
attach all the ornaments and lights to
the tree so that they wouldn't be blown
off by the wind
the Queen's Christmas tree is now the
magnet at Windsor Castle and is drawing
plenty of attention it's magnificent
right in front of the castle it's
beautiful I like it it's tall and well
proportioned it's just gorgeous it's
very nice and it's like a magical
Christmas tree from cobalt can be
admired at Windsor Castle until January
the safe
you